hi in this video we'll talk about the
classifications of bacteria on the basis
of their nutrition
so like any other organism bacteria
needs
nutrition to grow
and that's pretty simple
now let's talk about what is the basis
of the classification so there are
several criterias based on which we can
classify them such as the carbon sources
that they get the energy sources or the
electron sources that they utilize
so based on carbon sources there could
be two divisions
one could be autotrophs which use
co2 as the principal carbon source one
could be heterotroph which use
organic carbon as its source such as
reduced or preformed molecules from
other organisms
now in terms of energy sources they are
subdivided into two groups
phototrophs that ones which use a
light as an energy source and
chemotrophs
where where the energy source is
actually organic or inorganic molecule i
mean by their oxidation
the energy is generated
and lastly based on electron sources
they can be classified into lithotrops
where the electron source is reduced in
organic molecules
and organelle drops where the source of
electron is organic molecules
so these are the basic elements or basic
nomenclatures or set of rules that would
help us to understand and classify a set
of bacteria
now
these are like filters that we apply for
our google search
we can have one filter at a time we can
have multiple filters at time
so so far what we have looked at is
basically nothing but one filter at a
time now there could be complicated
classification schemes where we have to
use many of these filters together to
get a better understanding or better
define our category of bacteria so let's
try to understand that so let's classify
the microbes based on several filter
criterias and all the filter criteria
that we'll be using are three of these
together that means energy sources
electron sources and carbon sources
together as a filter would be used for
these classification and if we use these
three filters there would be five
classes of bacteria
namely
spoiler alert these names are pretty
difficult to pronounce
so it's
photo litho autotrophy
or photolito litho autotrophs
photo litho organotrophy
chemo litho autotrophy chemo litho
heterotrophy
then chemo organo heterotrophy
now all these names look super absurd
and weird and almost nothing could be
made out of these names but if we know
how to read these names then a lot of
information can be retrieved by just
looking at the name so let us look at
that part
so these you can imagine as a bacterial
nomenclature system
i mean it is not a nomenclature system
it's a classification system based on
nutrition but think in a simple term
it's basically a bacteria's name where
photo
over the first syllable means the energy
source second syllable means the
electron source and the third syllable
means the carbon source here photo means
the energy is derived from light
remember in our
uh one filter criteria we have defined
all of these things like photo are all
those organisms that take energy from
the
light
such similarly the electron sources
are derived from inorganic
donors when we see the term litho and
autotrophy means the carbon source is
co2 now it makes sense and many bacteria
fall under these category like
cyanobacteria green sulfur bacteria
purple sulfur bacteria to give you some
idea about these
classification now
now we know that overall
these nomenclature are not so difficult
bacterias has three different syllables
in their name and we just need to
understand what does these syllables
mean and by looking at these syllables
what we can
interpret about their nutritional
requirement so all these names has their
own meaning in terms of nutritional
requirement and that can be understood
easily let's try it together the next
category is photo organo heterotroph
looking at the term photo you can easily
understand the energies derived from
light
organo means
it is deriving its electron from an
organic donor and heterotrophy means it
use organic carbon instead of co2
some examples are green non-sulfur
bacteria purple non-sulfur bacteria
then next category says
chemo-litho-autotrophy now it's really
easy to interpret right chemo that means
light the energy is not getting getting
from light but the energy source is
inorganic chemicals
then litho means electron sources in
organic donor and autotrophy means the
carbon source is from co2 very simple
hydrogen oxidizing bacteria methanogens
fall under these categories
chemo litho heterotrophy is the next
category
again we can understand chemo means
organic chemicals serve as an energy
sources not light
litho means electron sources are derived
from inorganic toner
and carbon sources are occupied from
organic carbon not co2 so that tells us
about the nutritional requirement of
this category sulphur oxidizing bacteria
such as bigiota
megiotua actually falls under this
category
then
chemo organoheterotrophy is the last
category you can clearly understand
chemo means inorganic chemicals
electron sources are
organic donor because it's organo and
then heterotrophy means carbon sources
are derived from organic carbon not co2
most
non-photosynthetic microbes fall under
this category
now
now what i wanted to tell you that we
started with complicated names but now
we understand how to read these names
and what these names can actually tell
us about bacteria's nutritional
requirement now next time when they talk
about any of these complicated names you
have the solution i hope this short
video was interesting enough
so overall in this video we looked at
basis of classification we can use one
basis as one filter to classify bacteria
like simple classifications autotrophs
or heterotrophs we can also use a
combination of these criterias as
filters in terms of classifying the
bacteria in in one set we saw three of
these criteria could be used together to
classify them into five groups and we
understood what these nutritional
requirements really means in terms of
the sources of carbon energy and
electron
so i hope this is useful if you like
this video don't forget to support my
channel in patreon you can use my um
beam upi qr code to pay me in veeam
small contribution means a lot to me
my courses are there in academy which is
india's biggest learning platform you
can use my code mp10 to get a 10
discount thanks for listening
and don't forget to like share